im moment geht ja die 16 8 geht um die
idee einfach nur innerhalb von acht
stunden essen und dann 16 stunden pause
machen aber wirkt das wirklich oder ist
das alles nur einbildung ein
forschungsteam von der university of
story ist der these jetzt nachgegangen
und trat sie überprüft allerdings gibt
es einen haken klicks und science
fiction
hier gibt's täglich faszinierendes 1
videos abonniert den kanal nur dann und
nur dann verpasst er nichts los geht's
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen in einer
zehnwöchigen studie untersuchte das
forschungsteam wie sich die änderung der
essenszeiten auf das gewicht und andere
gesundheitliche faktoren auswirkt die
teilnehmer und teilnehmerinnen wurden in
zwei gruppen eingeteilt diejenigen die
das frühstück um 90 minuten verzögern
und 90 minuten früher zu abend essen
sollten und diejenigen die wie
gewöhnlich mahlzeiten essen als
kontrollgruppe im gegensatz zu früheren
studien musste sich niemand an eine
strenge diät halten und alle konnten
frei essen was sie wollten nur nicht
wann sie wollten obwohl es keine
einschränkungen gab stellte das
forschungsteam fest dass diejenigen die
ihre essenszeiten änderten insgesamt
weniger zu sich nahm als die
kontrollgruppe
dieses ergebnis wurde durch antworten
auf einen fragebogen gestützten 57
prozent der befragten bestätigte dass
sie weniger aßen gründe verminderter
appetit und generell weniger es
gelegenheiten und tatsächlich ist der
effekt der geänderten es zeiten
frappierend das forschungsteam fand
heraus dass diejenigen die ihre
essenszeiten änderten im durchschnitt
mehr als doppelt so viel körperfett
verloren als diejenigen in der
kontrollgruppe die zu den üblichen
zeiten lassen wenn diese pilot daten in
größeren studien wiederholt werden
können so das forschungsteam besteht die
möglichkeit dass die zeit beschränkte
nahrungsaufnahme einen breiten nutzen
sogar insgesamt für die gesundheit hatte
war
studienleiter dr johnson johnson dazu
obwohl diese studie klein ist hat sie
uns wertvolle einblicke gegeben wie
geringfügige änderungen unserer
essenszeit in unseren körper
beeinflussen können die verringerung des
körperfetts verringert unsere chancen an
fettleibigkeit und verwandten
erkrankungen zu erkranken und ist daher
für die verbesserung der allgemeinen
gesundheit von entscheidender bedeutung
doch es gibt einen haken denn 57 prozent
der befragten meinen dass sie die neuen
essen zeit nicht länger als die
vorgeschriebenen zehn wochen hätten
einhalten können ihr argument die
geänderten essenszeiten seien nicht mit
dem familien und sozial leben vereinbar
43 prozent der teilnehmer und
teilnehmerinnen würden jedoch in
erwägung ziehen mit flexibleren
essenszeiten fortzufahren dazu johnston
wie wir bei diesen teilnehmern gesehen
haben ist es jedoch schwierig fasten
diäten zu befolgen die möglicherweise
nicht immer mit dem familien und sozial
leben vereinbar sind wir müssen daher
sicherstellen dass sie flexibel und
förderlich für das wirkliche leben sind
da die potenziellen vorteile solcher
diäten offensichtlich sind
es scheint ihr also wirklich einen weg
gefunden worden zusammen mit einem ganz
einfachen trick gesünder leben zu können
allerdings gibt es noch etwas was so
richtig gesund ist abnehmen und muskeln
aufbauen unbedingt hier draufklicken das
aktuelle video von peitings nach etwas
mehr als einem jahr gibt es wieder
videos von finden also unbedingt
abonnieren und ansonsten bis dann bleibt
dran